[Music]
happy Tuesday everybody I'm Peter Brown
here with Miguel concepción hello
alright we're gonna play a final fantasy
12 today we do screams everyday at 11
a.m. and well that makes you 12
remastered the zodiac age is that the
subtitle yes that just came out today so
we're gonna hop right into it Miguel
gave me me 9 out of 10 there's a lot to
talk about this game so let's hop over
and see what we're working with so now
we are in let's say the middle of the
game in this temple called the still
shrine of Miriam this incidentally is
the math to jump too far ahead but this
incidentally is the area where you can
set your characters to auto level farm
okay well so before we get to that yeah
I'm sure a lot of people know what final
fantasy 12 is but for those who don't
what sort of sets us apart from other
Final Fantasy games because it it's
pretty distinct oh absolutely I mean it
comes from many of the developers who
worked on vagrant story and Fantasy
Tactics it I mean it is unusual for
mainline Final Fantasy for having built
upon an existing game universe but it's
a really great universe to build off but
I guess what I'm getting at here what
I'm hinting at is the the combat system
and the way that you sort of handle your
characters and manage the right battle
because it's maybe more like an MMO than
your regular follow fantasy games yeah
it's the gambit system which which is
unique to this game and incidentally has
never really been replicated in any
other drug therapy juice I could think
of I mean I think the Xenoblade games
kind of have some degree of
even then like kind of barely yeah yeah
so it's based on a priority command
prioritization system where you work off
on a whole bunch of if-then commands in
the in my review I sort of described it
as a fisher-price level of programming
where basically all the things that you
typically do in an RPG battle in your
brain yeah in your brain and that can
typically like you know the your best
intentions where you know when you get a
status ailment you want there's a
conservative part of you always wants to
cure yourself before you do anything
else say like you know continue
attacking an enemy what you can do is
set those kinds of styles to status
ailment fixes so that before your
character resumes attacking right so all
these things are being addressed so an
event happens in battle and essentially
your party automatically reacts based on
these things that you've set on it which
can be simple or complex which is kind
of going back to what you were saying
about level farming which if I think
you're talking about what I think you're
talking about is sort of one of the
aspects that makes this game you know
broken quote-unquote so how intense is
that process to actually make it so your
basic levelling up automatically it's
not that's that's the beauty of the game
it's actually not too complex when you
sort of understand what you have to do
to a level form essentially this is one
enemy in the temple who can spawn who
can summon these zombies and all you got
to do is commit is doesn't let your
party focus on the zombies and ignore
this one demon that is summoning two
zombies
that particular creature has a hit point
has hit points of beyond 3000 so all you
got to do is set your attack to only
attack enemies below 3000 hit point
gotcha
so that is that's the way to guarantee
that you won't kill the creature that's
summoning this alright okay so you're
essentially you're gaining experience
points or whatever based on individual
actions not on completing a battle
without I'm here the experience yeah
because you're talking about level
grinding but you're saying you also
don't want to kill the monster correct
so so is it like tactics foundation
tactics in that regard for every
individual action you take you were in a
little you earn you earn experience
which every with every enemy that you
kill so you'll get the experience to
killing the zombies oh so okay but they
keep responding to alright okay that was
the thing I was right
alright so let's see some of this
[Music]
so this is on my controller right so
then here's a question I have if you're
able to sort of settle these things to
work on their own how does combat
actually feel fulfilling is it the fact
that you were able to come up with these
you know sort of automated processes is
it the fact that you've leveled up
enough I mean does it ever feel that
things are just sort of maybe two passes
no actually I mean you have to
this is enemy over here they call it a
category called elementals that I
intentionally leave like ran away from
because I believe this this creature is
actually too high leveled performing so
like a lot of the food I give them like
field of battle has a mix of enemies
that you should be qualified to take on
or once you reach that area but it does
try to the mapless try to throw in some
curveballs with a higher level and this
one I guess I've leveled high enough
that this guy been good to be a problem
but when I first came to this area
he was definitely someone you wanted to
avoid so is that kind of the biggest
challenge you're gonna face is just
these like you know curve balls these
really high level enemies and obviously
there's a lot of Secrets to find in each
given map there is there's a hunting
component in the game it actually
factors into the narrative
we're various folks in different parts
of the of the world sent out these
bounties and you could like hunt these
like high-level creatures what one is
that one this one dragon is actually
named after Matt suno the the one who
got sumimasen
yeah the game's dirt well one of the
directors he sort of left this project
but he was involved with a bigger story
with fungus tactics over battle and he
was a he's credited with I guess the
story and the concept
I mean overall I mean again it goes back
to you the fact that you created this
these commands yourself I mean there is
there is definitely this sense of
ownership here's a situation where I
needed to I probably could have taken
these flying creatures a little bit more
efficiently by setting a gambit where I
would emphasize ranged attacks because
as you can tell some of these melee
passion I kidding
yeah so it give me like a little bit of
a primer on the story here because
unfortunately is big about the fan amaz
of Monsuno and all the other guys he
works with who also worked on this game
I tend to sort of every time I try to
play twelve zone out within the first
hour because the story is is just dumped
upon you so yeah help me understand in
simple terms what the plot is here I
know there's a regicide I know there's
warring kingdoms so how is it different
than Final Fantasy 15 which has a very
similar definitely it's definitely not a
roadtrip right fantasy $0.12 basically a
lot of the point though the main players
specific the folks in your party are
basically folks who were served like
caught in the crossfire of this war
between these two large kingdoms
because there were two smaller kingdoms
in between these larger kingdoms make
sure I got no body and dalmasca are the
two smaller kingdoms ash here the girl
I'm controlling she's the princess of
dalmasca and the two larger kingdoms are
Rosaria and arcadia so there is a big
war and there are small players caught
in the middle right what what what the
hell can these guys do what are they
what do they have well actually they're
let's see here the guy with the spear
Bosh he is this disgraced and framed
general who worked for gal masca and he
along with the rest of the party is
helping ash find essentially proof of
her legitimacy to the throne I see okay
because it's established pretty early on
in the game that people thought that she
had killed herself of the out of grief
for losing her husband in the war okay
but is she related to the king that's
murdered at the start of the game
daughter I'm starting sure we're talking
with yeah I mean that's that's I mean
that's the beauty and the the down side
of these games seventy believes you know
that it's you you're just on one hand
it's a lot to take in on the other hand
you know you just
I mean I'm comfort to Spector wanting to
learn as much like cancer so I can
understand things yeah and one things I
mentioned in my review is how it does
feel like a middle episode to a much
larger saga which I which is sort of
like how the vagrant story feels they're
sort of I haven't played classy tactics
in a while but they're sort of the
implication that there's like so much
going on building up sort of it actually
it starts you off in the middle of an
event like which is you could call the
middle chapter of the story and then it
keeps you back to the events before them
leading up to it but then it also skips
ahead and jumps over that initial midway
it's definitely uh yeah I mean Monsuno
knows how to make his music
I don't think that's that's what he's
going for but I'd say he definitely has
a a problem with like having names that
are very similar to one another mm-hmm
because there's like two of the kingdoms
have like a name that is basically
identical and abroad eeeh and now but
yeah come on
that's a no yeah and I mean one's an
actual Kingdom in there that looks like
a cabbage so just to remind folks we are
playing final fantasy 12 the zodiac age
this is the remastered version of the
PlayStation 2 game which has a bunch of
new changes to it beyond just the
graphics and one of them I actually want
to ask about is the license board right
it kind of a controversial aspect of the
game maybe even beyond the way the
gambit system works but the license
board is used to literally allow you to
equip certain items or use certain items
even right I mean everything that you're
going to learn or where you have to
navigate this right which is this
confusing it's not confusing I mean you
could argue that it could the whole idea
of having to earn the qualifications to
earn like saint level 1 armor it seems
like you could have saved a step but at
the same time one benefit of the license
board is that it helps make each
character specialize in a certain job
field okay it's I would say overall it's
an improvement over the original job
board because you have if everyone maxed
out their board it was a shared board in
the original game then everyone could
have been the same and yeah it just like
makes makes it a little boring there's a
point
I think maybe one third into the game
where you get your first Esper which is
this games version of summons where
you're able to select your second job
now here's the license board selection
screen which has been enhanced over the
international version of Final Fantasy
12 that came out like a year or two
after the original version which had ten
jobs now there's 12 me wanting to
explore the different types of jobs I
wanted to give everyone a different job
though if you wanted everyone to be a
knight if you wanted everyone to be a
monk you could have done that but in the
case of my first playthrough I wanted to
just you know just try everything out so
there are six characters 12 jobs total
and we have the chance for each
character to have two jobs correct can
you alter your choices after you pick a
job nope
it's locked in that that is weird to me
but it's kind of risky from like a game
development standpoint when you're
considering a game this big it's very
much a it feels like the original Final
Fantasy MetroCard works like you got
you're gonna choose a path man like
right now at the very start a game but
do you find that that feels restricting
or is there enough to explore well for
me to play devil's advocate I mean you
will be forced to pick your initial job
and you'll have the chance to preview
all the different boards yeah but so
when I was playing this and I previewed
the board I was like that's cool I have
no idea what the hell I'm looking at so
even though I previewed it does that do
any good for a new player cuz it's
really hard to understand I think if you
have some background in role-playing
games you should be able to like there a
spot I mean you're throwing shade right
now I've got background you know I just
learned the term throwing shade maybe
like six months ago I think that's
that's kind of work right around it's a
little milder maybe it's a little bit
older but ma'am it's
it's code for you being
passive-aggressive I didn't as laughs
right oh my gosh well if you have a
problem getting into it then I mean look
it's I don't know if the game really
goes I don't remember going out of its
way to kind of explain this stuff to me
I mean it doesn't take a little bit of
trial and error to really sort of feel
like you get the hang of this
right I mean understanding that you know
your characters need armor except weird
is always a bonus and where this stuff
even comes from like when I was looking
at some things it was like okay maybe
this item I want to equip it but I don't
know if I'm gonna get that item like is
it gifted to me when i unlock it on the
job board no so I have to bring up the
code for the shops right which but is it
just in the shops like do you find out
you can find the most you can find them
in the fields like bear I mean rarely
through enemies but you know these
little chests here there's a semi
randomized sometimes you'll get you'll
get Gil sometimes you will get items
sometimes you'll get really really rare
yeah access to talk to me about this
from one rare thing as a Lance or
something like that
zodiac Lance I did not get it in this
one okay so but what like how does that
that particular item work it's like one
box in the beginning of the game that
you don't you're not supposed to open it
and then at the end of the game if you
open it you might get the lair suppose
this is this this happens in the
original game where you had to avoid
opening certain chests diabolical yeah
awful there was no there was no way for
anyone to do the game does that hint or
guide you as to which chest you should
avoid so that's one things I really
dislike the only thing I really dislike
about the original game yeah the fact
that I think you needed to get the
walkthrough to learn how to do it and
you know and it was it was interesting
but it wasn't it was getting that spear
to zodiac spear was not essential for
beating the game right just like a
little like kudos kind of a thing you
know for for caring enough to maybe
replay it with a walkthrough or dive
deep I mean I was reading an interview
with one of the guys who sort of the the
principle behind the remastered version
who also worked on the original game I
mean his life has been found fantasy 12
almost forever
and he was saying like yeah we decided
not to take out for example the the
experience farming glitch because we
actually like having those things in
there you know these sort of quirky like
why did they do this it almost seems
unfair but it's like a rewarding
challenge cement they wanted to give
players that opportunity to break the
game and so I'm like the absolute value
of that but the opposite version is
burying an item in a chest that you need
to open random or not open random it's
absurd and as far as I know that that is
not in the zodiac page really yes so
then you can't get the item at all I
believe you I didn't go far enough as I
said in my my body line I only put in
like 50 hours in yeah only but
I believe I've heard that earning it is
gonna be a lot easy whether you buy it
later on yeah the one things I did want
to mention are some of the enhancements
to the game aside from the cleaned up
textures and high-definition visuals
with watching me play right now is it's
almost jarring because I'm double speed
and I've been playing at 4 times speed
you know when you start playing in the
fact using the fast-forward options when
you go back to the normal speed it's
almost looks like ash ash is like
running through water yeah so Miguel's
referring to this game lets you speed up
the action by two times or four times to
help the process of these automated
battles just go by and to run around the
field faster this is 2 X right yes now
kick it up to 4 and if you what you
gonna do it with a button press right
it's not well you have to choose you
have to choose like a maximum yeah you
have to settle on a maximum but some if
you play some of these maps I mean if
you've covered a lot of these maps like
thoroughly you've checked every corner
you've opened up every chest which by
the way actually responds and have new
and have new contents every time you
every time they respawn you can pretty
much like a nice like you know getting
around at 4 times speed is actually not
you just completed in 2 battles right
pick the blink of an eye right yeah I
mean I look forward to possibly getting
ash who's my highest level care to the
level 99 like even before hitting the 60
hour mark of the game which be like
looking back on my original playthrough
it's kind of crazy because I think I got
my first level 99 character in the
original game and public took me at
least 120 hours
so I want to know is this the best
looking cast in all of Final Fantasy
everyone is pretty freaking attractive
in this game look at them all yeah
they're pretty attractive and I love
that they I love that they you know
they're all consistent with sort of the
ivelisse aesthetic yes which has a lot
to do with the involvement of Akihiko
Yoshida who's also the illustrator
behind games like bravely default the
noseless wanders it knows this one who's
and file a fancy 14 as well and 11 yeah
which character is BAE Gugu wants to
know and we and we have to again say
[Music]
let's say ash yeah yeah I know
Ferran has a really big following yes
I'm a girl who wears sort of a cat bunny
well I think that I find very fast I
don't know I would love to talk to the
localization team on how they settled on
her New York accent for the English
voice acting oh great I mean I I know
nothing about Japanese accents so I mean
I don't know if she has a very eccentric
one
but yeah that also does bring up the
option to actually change the music I
mean the voice acting to Japanese
on-the-fly and I believe in
interestingly enough the soundtrack has
been great
you know hitoshi sakimoto yeah but this
entire time we've actually been playing
in the original using the original music
I'm switching to reoriented interesting
interesting a thing about the toggling
is that the orchestrated music doesn't
appear immediately it actually sort of
fate it takes about five minutes by five
seconds for it to fade in it's great
playing through headphones because you
could it just sounds like you can hear
sort of like the fullness a lot of like
the low frequency and bass so we're at
where are we in the world right now what
are we looking at we are in transit this
is a part of the game where we had to
make our way to that shrine that we
started in this is the path that you had
to go to to get this other piece of this
other
to prove Franz legitimate I mean um
ashes legitimacy to the throne just
Franz outfit ever come up because I'm
saying heels and I mean a bathing suit
it's probably not the best way to run
around the snow I'm sure they never
address it dude no no of course yeah
it's pretty quick yes
I am gonna try to find the best way to
get
so the fact that we're the snowstorm
also brings to attention the fact that
some of these outdoor areas have
changing weather systems which also
which affect the kinds of enemies that
you'll encounter is it like in order of
like a lot of enemies or just you know a
couple particularly more hostile enemies
appear like they appear after more
hostile enemies appear in more hostile
weather systems going back to the
progression and activity you know we're
playing at four times the speed and like
getting through these enemies rather
quickly as you can see from killing each
one we get to pressure Awards one being
LP which stands for licensed point you
get a minimum of one per character
I mean per killed but some enemies who
are harder
well sometimes offer too
interestingly enough LP that you'd get
with each with each kill everyone and
everyone in your group all six of them
actually earned that milk that's good as
opposed to experience which only applies
it to the active players right the ones
who actually make a difference right and
you're not all pulling from the same LP
pool correct brand console hot we are
running the game at four times the
normal speed because why the hell not
I'm curious if we are coming up to any
sort of story stuff because I would like
to see how the cutscenes and the voice
acting and the character is actually
coming out touch the crystal link touch
the crystal link it's a natural line it
is in my head through shoot at my boss I
knows your boss and I cross I am I don't
know what I am okay
where am i who am i what am i doing here
see unfortunately it's not oh we've go
to our Katie's okay look hit real
exciting to chat I don't know but keep
it up it's good I like it when you a
little excitement all right it's really
cool but don't call us game stop
yeah the summer is a little bit slow in
terms of new releases right now which i
think is probably smart of square-enix
to release this game right now because I
think the point one of the things I hear
from so many people when they talk about
this game is I couldn't keep up with it
or I never gave it a chance back in the
day and yeah I will say I mean one of my
criticisms is just the onboarding and
yeah I mean looking back on my very
first playthrough final fantasy 12 I
probably I probably didn't get the
gambit system until maybe five hours
into um having it introduced to go back
to showing the front of his face what
was going on with the lighting there I
don't know if we can recreate it now all
right I know his cheeks look like super
weird to me
man okay sorry
all right so we are on the Death Star
pretty much because we actually do have
to rescue the princess right but they
weren't on the Death Star when they
rested the princess they were on a
bigger ship that can't start destroyer
they are on a Star Destroyer when they
rescued the princess at the beginning of
a new hope it's nothing I'll be fine
yeah yes come on let's go what are you
waiting for Pinellas still out there
that's really [ __ ] they won't be
long we will talk later also why is this
guy wearing armor in space I guess well
they're not in space well they are in
there in space see I'm all about the one
with the majesty that guy will come to
you no not him yeah trust his sword we
must trade or no I see no other way we
track back commandeer a ship and make
our escape cuz the guy with the puffy
sleeves talked about fire has to talk
yeah okay a majesty cannot abide
weakness least of all in herself
we must make her confront the reality of
our plight I'm sorry I was watching to
get through no I mean what if it's got
to wrap up the guy ah he's not he was
just standing there to do with like the
white puffy sleeves and sort of the
sweater vests been going on balthier
Balti a bulkier bulkier yeah yeah yeah
Seinfeld pirate it's big
[Music]
oh yeah you could turn off the icy sub
my in the previous a file I use you
could actually turn off the mountains
right targeting lines so the blood rose
88 is asking if I can't control my
character I'm not buying and you do
control your character but you don't do
it actively you can always change up
right change up your commands yeah you
can issue commands like this whatever
you want to but what you're really doing
is setting up commands ahead of time
you're basically programming these
characters so even if you're not
controlling them during combat you see
you you have control over what they're
doing all the things that you are going
to be doing anyway this game just
strange life is three months but it's
certainly easy to imagine a life
for some people and it was for me it was
sort of a turn-off but it's like I don't
feel like I have the agency over what's
actually happening but again I also
didn't get very far into the game so I
can't really do it but everyone who has
played it seems to really like it in
terms of you know people who have played
the games I in the initial hours someone
died because grant is spending too much
time stealing
[Music]
how good one of the things I love and
you mentioned a little bit your review
as it ties in to the story but I love
playing as thieves in games because some
really times that's the best that's the
way to get like the best secret armor
I'll bring it back to Final Fantasy
Tactics cuz why the hell not the Genji
armor is like this this incredible armor
set that you can't you have to get from
this vampire character who's very very
strong and dangerous and to actually be
able to survive while stealing his armor
which you have a very low percentage
chance of doing and then still have
enough people left to kill him well I'm
not losing characters to Bernadette was
a very rewarding is for the combat
scenario so is the thieving stuff in
this game more for just like resources
and like basic items or can you actually
steal
pretty useful equipment from enemies you
can steal I mean rare items not
necessarily equipment but I will say
this is the first game that really made
me pay attention and value thievery well
but you know but they do in a way that
it's basically mandatory
I mean after you've killed you know your
first dozen or so enemies you realize
that they don't have any cash yeah and
you're wondering how do I get money and
then maybe Brian crime is how you get
maybe me yeah maybe the the game could
been more effective in communicating
this but it's through the selling of all
the loot drops and stealing yeah that's
how you get money and if you actually
sell enough items
you will actually the the scores will
actually have like these brand-new
survey's that these item bundles as
rewards for selling them oh yeah it's
yeah if you go to the shop they've
leased thing this aside from buy and
sell they always have a third option
called bazaar
so you're damned wait you're you're
dying here what's going on am i
distracting you or is this a tough
these guys are wolves it's been a while
since I played with these low low level
versions but technically I should be
capable
you haven't pulled around with
doesn't give itself
[Music]
and obviously you can equip armor but
that doesn't really have a superficial
difference on your character right it's
just weapons that you actually see
correct
so that that guy who's accompanying you
that the United that was a boss ler he
doesn't stick around on your party
doesn't know there's a I mean the game
does have a number of guest characters
you know it's sort of like it adds to
the story especially when they can he's
definitely not the only character with
guest stars there are a lot of deaths
just die in general like story based you
know main characters dying there are
some nice twists and I've seen my share
of like write-ups you know just playing
this in the context of like you know
this decade and like how how much in
like pop culture right now we're just so
crazy about Game of Thrones you know
there are some sort of like Game of
Thrones level we never like twists and
whatnot yeah Montana's games have always
sort of it goes back in a way and even
like the sort of I guess the different
factions I mean they're referred to as
houses yeah like how solid or
spending more time fighting do I have
being
[Music]
how is the dungeon design in general and
I was playing a little bit I also turned
this map on confused but I felt like
well why not right but then I realized
that wasn't playing the dungeon I was
playing the map right it sort of reminds
me of of like how Mel Gear Solid almost
just feels like pac-man but you're
playing though yeah you're playing the
radar exactly it's okay I think I would
have preferred an option to turn to that
maybe you will follow me we must reach
the airships before they do you would
let us leave knowing who we are lady
Ashe by all rights you would not even to
exist that you and Captain Ronson Berg
were made to appear dead is like a
hidden thread laid bare your actions
hereafter will pull at that thread and
we will see what yeah I mean if you're
really big fans of code translation
translator Alexander o Smaug good who's
had a hand in a lot of games a very
influential effort effort some of my
peers montt mentioned service experience
I was writing apparently there's a
little bit of good fortune
certain characters speak I'm just glad
it's not like let us go that's sort of
like the old English like right there
putting into Final Fantasy Tactics for
the War of the Lions remake you [ __ ]
sorry
no as I recall that that wasn't like
your main gripe about the game it's just
something about framerate or just like
the speed they slow down the animations
in combat purposefully which basically
add the opposite effect of what this
remastered is
but it also added in like a new couple
new classes I think and like PvP and all
this great stuff holidays attack this is
a real tragic game well never stop
talking or the Lions no I mean even the
original one is tragic in the sense that
the localization is not good like it's
it's got some weird quirks to the script
that just don't really make sense and
make following the story which is
confusing already even more difficult
and you know you're playing the lesser
version when you play that because it's
missing out on some class so like there
is in my opinion a better version of the
game but there is no perfect version of
innocence which incorporate features
from both of the games drinky-poo know
there is no beauty release for this feat
is dead sorry buried it a long time ago
I love it I love my betta actually
[Music]
an appealing gambit set because they
think we are at the front door of the
boss man here motion
sort of gambit to heal
[Music]
we've got some hi-potions the soundtrack
has some like industrial like house
music shape weird going on
it's very OneNote
[Music]
Mike my heart he's been talking about
playing Final Fantasy Tactics for a
while and I gave him my Vita but I
couldn't find my charging cable so he's
waiting for that to come and apparently
he's gonna play it I can't wait to hear
all the ways it's just like XCOM and
like Oh X time did it better
Mike's wrong that's okay I I just
finished this chat with Mike about X
comma I didn't know it's coming on the
same day I was restore peace to down
mascot no matter we hope the proof of
your royal lineage a maid of passing
resemblance will serve our purposes now
as for you my dear
the Empire requires you know so this
guy's a judge couple judges the
nethicite they're like a bunch of Darth
Vader's yeah I was gonna say he's like
Darth Vader but he's not the walls like
five of them
I got a get friend to stop stealing so
then again the boss might have something
worse hey how do you feel about X comma
- I'm gonna bring it back to that real
quick
but you got to keep playing that's
that's the trick actually we are under
embargo no I mean just in general not
about Oh X come - yeah I'll jump I'll
tell you I haven't a I haven't taken to
the procedural as procedural like map
aspect of it and I I've tried playing
that game so many times and I don't it's
not that I don't get it but I don't get
why people love hmm let's put it down
have you compared to the original
XCOM I didn't play the original nice
combo but I don't think that
disqualifies my opinion right okay
frankly I mean I thought it was a bold
direction for a sequel to have a premise
where basically story doesn't matter and
you can sort of rat mechanics around
procedural missions yeah I'm sorry what
do you have you have already been
talking about this a lot on the lobby
because clearly it comes it comes up
often but I but I tried playing
XCOM 2 last week I was like all right
there's an expansion coming out to be
big maybe I'll tackle that expansion and
mike tells next com2 is so good maybe
his favorite game ever I don't I don't
get it there are aliens were soldiers
let's move one square at a time and stop
those aliens I mean I could see why he
would like it a lot but I'm surprised
it's anyone's favorite
you know the way we all have wrong
opinions gosh what's my wrong opinion
understand that wrong
I don't know mine I need to I think I
need to accept the fact that I think
over time I mean Mel Gear Solid 3
doesn't age as well as I wish it did
have you played the 3ds version I played
doubles up yes so I think I would argue
although I haven't played the HD
remastered version but I'd also don't
know if it carries over the most
important feature in the 3d version well
there are two the 3d version lets you
aim in first-person but it also lets you
walk while crouching which the
playstation 2 version did not which is a
pretty big deal
there you go that version holds up I
think I think I'm just what is it what
is it about I'm just like we're calling
the cumbersome nosov the camouflage
system you know every time I play that
game I just eventually just forget about
using all that it's just not yeah it's
pretty cumbersome I mean the one the one
thing that I will always have a soft
spot for it was the very first stealth
game I played where I was rewarded for
like going into new area not doing a
single thing until I had studied all the
enemy saw patrol patterns and just
taking all this visual information and
then going to the attendant clearing it
out getting every item knocking everyone
out and getting to the exit of that area
hmm without ever being seen and that was
the first time I ever experienced a
stealth game so was it someone just said
yeah 0hx e07 no Crouch walk in the PSP
version there you go all right there's
no Crouch walk in the PSP version of
sneaking geez how does that affect the
overall experience at all
it lets you it lets you hide an attack
simultaneously what an odd thing to
remove well that's the thing is they
didn't really remove it if they just
ported the PlayStation version because
it was added to the 3ds version
[Music]
zero apparently knows mgs3 very well I'm
glad that my memory serves me correctly
I just I was always worried about
declaring facts I love I mean and just
going to from like the the Snake Eater
version to the subsistence version yeah
and when they freed up that camera yeah
it was like practically a new game yeah
no there's little changes I should wear
it close to my heart
in a review no one's called yet I really
don't like that guy's arms what the hell
is that he looks like a license board
like a walking meet with him give ear to
his words it almost seems inspired by
yes no I know what you're talking about
that is weird he says his armor before
bond or it's so great he's got shorts on
and we can't blame Tetsu Nomura either
oh we can we might not be right about
there majesty I would ask you for some
time I must some other way until I
should find it I would have Bosh remain
at your side bar doubt him you may I
know you very well Sean Connery no I
miss doing impressions without being my
return and we all go through a Sean
Connery phase or Christopher Walken
phase I really learned early on I cannot
do Christopher Walken yeah I'll let
other people do it I mean I I do you
know J Moore does not get enough credit
for being a better Impressionists and
Kevin Spacey the one thing I would like
to jump to next is what they call the
trial trial mode which is to the judges
put you on trial
pretty much it's it's an enemy rush
that's a lot of savegames and these
aren't even all my saved games I mean
the last 20 hours of my playthrough has
been at home and I've been too lazy to I
forgot to transfer my most latest save
file for this livestream today I there
are a hundred levels which I believe has
most if not all of the enemies you'll
encounter in the game with Ashe being in
the 60s
I believe we're probably gonna last
maybe no more than thirty rounds but it
goes by quickly because we got four
times speed
did you ever this kind of reminds me of
the I forget how it was phrased but it
was sort of like the the trials are like
the little arena mode in seven and the
golden saucer I never played that
oh wait and never played the saucer I
played seven oh man so golden saucer was
great distraction I actually really
liked finding out the game but one of
the things it has is this little you
know it's it's more like a stage and you
walk onto the stage and it runs a
roulette wheel and the roulette wheel
will give you various conditions that
are handicaps or no not handicaps they
they're hindrances right so it's like
everyone's poisoned or no one can use
magic stuff like that and if you get
these really difficult ones which you
earn by winning fight after fight you
can get some really high level gear and
like some materia that's pretty rare and
and just some like you know like ex
potions and stuff like that that's super
useful and was always like rolling the
dice because you never really knew what
you're going to get with that roulette
wheel does that was held a lot of fun
hmm
well though I guess this is probably
more aptly compared to the what are they
towers in Disgaea and if you play much
this guy anybody you've got they've got
like you know floored challenges that I
think
in a game were like the max levels 9990
it's ridiculous yeah I don't even know
if there is a max level anymore it's
getting some nuts
you get congratulate every ten rounds
and you get these items that can
transfer to the main game like
handkerchiefs like handkerchiefs which
actually is very good when you get runny
nose the oil status ailment just wipe
the oil off you couldn't do that anyway
I forgot they don't bathe no pulse other
one makes a good point someone asks is
this game free to play and he says no
game is free to play because every game
takes a little piece of us with it yeah
so in this mode you do get LP which
which you can which applies to the main
game but you do not get XP
we got was pointed sheet of paper so
that I remind you that we are watching
while he's playing I'm watching final
fantasy 12 the zodiac age a remastered
underappreciated PlayStation 2 RPG that
falls within and perhaps over
appreciated RPG series but this is one
that not many people played and it's
been remastered for the PlayStation 4
not on Vita not on PC not on Xbox one
ps4 exclusive and Miguel how far are you
into the game at this point when you hit
these trials I'm about halfway through
the game and I'm already getting my butt
kicked and this is a say he's already
gotten much farther than this this is
sort of a say that he's reverting to for
the stream Oh Matt does a good
impression of beef oh wow I need to see
that which man I don't know Matt a
Spinelli maybe unless there's another
Matt out there I don't know about I only
know of one Matt like in the world
see here I've got two bosses in a row Oh
Matt Padgett it could be Matt - huh
either way I can't imagine I mean no
we're all self-aware but - uh points I
know I can get the grumpy and sort of
fly off the handle but I don't know what
man yeah what put an impression of me be
like okay here we go damn dingo is
defending Mike XCOM 2 is great Mike is
right I'm not mad at you though Pete
it's not for everyone
you know what no game is for everyone
and once we're talking about Tetris that
game is for everyone I I will say damn
dingo that you are right but I will not
concede that Mike is really I'm sorry
but this goes beyond XCOM to Mike is
just wrong general thinking about XCOM 2
and it's procedurally generated maps are
there any rogue likes you really like
you know these guys remember no one
thing nice thing about the trials is
that the the the enemy makeup of each
stage does not change and it looks like
I will fail these guys belong in the
Dark Crystal or something mm-hmm I said
that about maybe not those enemies but
another set of enemies
all right let's see we are closing in on
the hour mark what do you got left to
show us what is the what is the final
act of our stream well we showed them we
shared a surprising amount of story that
I wasn't expecting the show um we can
just chill out of the beach this [ __ ]
all right
the fog coast I mean you've got a nice
Sheen I'm really pale and white I could
use some Sun hello couple of dudes are
sparring
vendor of goods yes and as I mentioned
before you know one thing that does keep
the veterans on their toes is that they
have mixed up the inventories of the
merchants so certain items favorite
items like I only have one embroidered
tippet which doubles the amount of XP
and I got one just out of luck I'm
opening up a chest in one of the later
areas in the previous game apparently
you could buy it from certain merchants
but not this time
man you know what I want to see before
we close out eventually is a summon the
Esper's oh yeah we can do oh yeah we
should do we should do a mist attack I I
don't know what that is but I can't wait
to see it it's a special attack with a
little bit of a roulette component okay
what can you hear now tried chocobos in
this can you you can oh well but there's
like one area where I needed to use it
to reach a part of the story that's
here's a problem with the for time speed
just getting that prompt to appear
because of just like that's we're how
the game takes you away from actual
combat and how much combat is essential
to leveling up so robos are basically
like get a jail free card
yeah are they limited in their use oh
yeah I can see it counting down right so
you have chuckle about time okay it's
exact time but yeah which you can renew
with just all greens right oh yeah this
is for time sweet Plus sprinting it's
one blurry Wow call the cops
guys speeding looking at it is like
making me nervous all right we are going
to basically lay waste to the field with
[Music]
quickening quickening is the special
effects
but
here's the summit
oh wait it's just hanging out with you
she's hanging out with you and just
really kicking ass but I was hoping for
the spectacle of it all there's a
spectacle but his timer needs to run out
he's got this little clock up a tiny
tiny clock icon can you can you so it'll
run out between battles it's like I'll
run out maybe give the guys some
animation and he's just rusting his
chest forward
listen he's got his whole his own thing
that you can yeah but he doesn't have
like gambits that you can invite in
doesn't know okay and he needs to I need
to run route what's he do
am i curing my oh wait I got a freaking
of mirror mail and here just
Oh
I'm okay I'm I'm reaching a new area
she'd uh uplands while the summons is on
so it's sounding a lot more dramatic
Dave really is
my time has run out okay
if they always do a nice finish assuming
they're targeting an enemy if not
they'll just disappear
I mean it's no nights of the round let's
flash no one actually wanted I mean
people wanted night sit around but to
use it in combat was meaning the ass
honest it was cool like the first 10
times you use it it's just
what was Sephiroth's attack with the
where he destroys the planets maybe it
was a form of Altima I don't think so
because you could get ultimate yourself
now the other thing I want to show are
the quickening yeah special attacks so
as you advance through the License Board
you everyone unlocks three quickening x'
that's just that's a weird term right
yeah and the AP we have to prep it you
can keep doing them as long as one of
the names in your party is highlighted
and then you press the corresponding
button like when now at the start of the
next quickening so there's a timer so
that's the reason why I'm sled and
mashing
so as long as the timer doesn't run out
you can just keep stringing these
attacks together
but the more you do it the quickening
the more powerful looking into Mordor
the more hit points you'll buy and if at
any point all three names are grayed out
then you have to hit the r2 button and
it will start this sort of roulette
rotation and when it stops you have to
hope that one of them is highlighted if
not you got to hit r2 again do they get
into why he has that scar actually yes
he could I think it appears in the
prologue oh it does I think so or he
gets when he gets captured and beat him
up beaten up okay
[Music]
blood rose I'm sorry I didn't have a
boss kita yes
we're just like we're just showing off
stuff
[Music]
like guys well there's a benefit to just
like stringing them I mean you can like
get the most powerful finishing
attacking I believe you can do like for
it's gonna do that punch thing again
yeah like for like level three attacks
plus for level two attacks
there are these like eight different or
ten different those are like Adam
elemental based finishers so I ran out
of time how was it a pull off ten hits
oh my god the cutting to see you a thing
hmm and then you find out which one you
get like a light base finisher totally
unnecessary for an enemy this level
right so there we go
gosh just leveled up well I think it's a
pretty good look at this game is there
anything else you want to showcase no we
went over some of the options we did
show the multiplier the changes in sound
yeah
I'm just I was just grateful that we've
had like so many opportunities to show
off this game both today and a couple
times with a Callie and if you go into
our YouTube channel you should be able
to find a whole bunch of other gameplay
sort of highlights was the the zodiac
age cool well thank you for joining us
everyone again this has been final
fantasy 12 the zodiac age and we are
doing this in our 11 o'clock a.m.
Pacific slot every single day we will
have a live stream of some sort on
GameSpot so be sure to subscribe on
Twitter on YouTube or comment GameSpot
and watch us thank you for watching
today there's been a lot of fun Miguel
thank you for playing final fantasy 12
and sharing your expertise I can't wait
to play this game but I'm also a little
bit worried it's gonna be too weird for
me we'll find out
alright everyone thanks a lot a
beautiful day
[Music]
you